there was me that is Alex and my three
droops at his Pete Georgie and dim and
we sat in the Korova Melbourne trying to
make up I received us what to do the
evening hey you guys it's Friday and
time for another movie review and just
as we promised we're doing another
Stanley Kubrick movie a Clockwork Orange
yeah classic movie I love this movie
honestly this is not only one of my my
probably my favorite Stanley Kubrick
movie this is one of my favorite top
five movies ever of all time of all
movies yeah it's pretty and it's pretty
close to the book too
it is quite faithful to the other than
the ending but we'll get into it right
and actually that's probably not
Kubrick's fault actually I guess Ben get
into it right now it was based on the
novel by Anthony Burgess now the story
goes that the American version because
the British book the American version of
the book had the infamous chapter 21 but
when the book was published in the US
the American publisher didn't like the
last chapter and left it out
Dana what's chapter 21 well in the book
you know and probably most people even
if you haven't seen the movie you're
probably quite familiar with the story
because it's been referenced so many
times like [ __ ] on The Simpsons has
been read it's like a zillion times and
stuff like that I haven't seen this
movie then there's got to be something
wrong you've got to go back and see this
movie this yet this is one that I'm
actually gonna say you need to see this
much yeah I mean because like it's just
so ubiquitous yeah it's it's a movie
that's taken place in England yeah in a
futuristic well for the time that the
stories being told kind of dystopian
world where the Soviet Union and Europe
have kind of merged into one thing and
it's not going too well it's about a
youth violence I guess you say it's a
gang gang of young hoodlums yeah and
what's happened to the criminal justice
system and there's a lot of philosophy
to it you'll see yeah and let's say - so
yeah so there's all this stuff going on
in the book and the protagonists of both
the book in the film Alex is pretty much
a straight-up psychopath yeah
he's a rapist he's a murderer he gets
off on just beating the [ __ ] out of
people and being as horrible as possible
he so let's just be like 17 I think in
the book in the book he's 15 the book is
50 now in the movie he's older they did
I guess they didn't want to go that
super controversial rock cuz like ice
actually in the book he's much worse
than in Roby so if you watch the movie
and it's disturbing and just like wow
what a [ __ ] even though you do kind of
empathize with them in the book he does
he does way way were [ __ ] yeah you you
but I can really understand why they
bumped his age up because actually
Malcolm McDowell who plays the the main
character Alex he's like 28 right yeah
it's 27 or 20 27 28 when he's doing the
movie he's supposed to be playing like a
17 or 18 years yeah I got the cuz he was
still he was supposed to be still in
school right but the thing is you gotta
understand like the legal problems you
know really have you know 15 year old
boys raping 12 year old girls and ten
year old girls on screen you that was
new though in the book you know it's
what kind of stuff that happened yeah
they know these were not good kids these
were hardcore criminals and really what
the book is about is about you know it's
Anthony Burgess is trying to show you
that people in society will trade their
rights away for safety to live a calm at
a calm life but it's not so simple when
you do that it was yeah I mean see
Kubrick does a good job showing or
illustrating the book yeah pretty good
and I mean like I said the movie is
fairly faithful to the book it does some
kind of Kubrick II and things that he
kind of brought to at his own reading of
it but like I said the reason that there
was controversy is because the final
chapter of the book actually has Alex
the central figure it shows him like
three years later and he is seemingly
outgrowing his youthful psychopathy and
it's suggested that he's going to go on
to have a normal life now what was what
happened was that when Kubrick was
making the movie he had read the
American edition of the book which
doesn't have that last chapter so he was
already like halfway into making the
move
before he even found out that the book
had a last chapter that was like a
redemptive kind of chapter and then he
said you know what I still don't want to
do it like that because he's like I
don't think that you know he's not
[ __ ] on the book cuz it's an awesome
book but I don't think that the
redemption was earned right I think I
would have bought it more if it was 20
years down the line but not when it's
just like a couple years that oh he now
he's 18 and he's like oh maybe I'll get
married and have a kid and I'll stop all
this stuff it just didn't feel like
because he is not he didn't have any
inkling in the rest of the story that he
wanted to change he just he was
basically just a monster yeah who
enjoyed it so I don't see it just wasn't
all that believable to me and then one
of the themes in the book and in the
movie is this concept and I think people
are starting to become you know more
used to this concept you know as
Internet it's kind of shed light on the
way governments and governments work the
government can't save you really in fact
a lot of them don't want to because
they're corrupt and you know that's
discussed in the movie too
you know they did crime is kind of a
human problem you know it has to be
solved by people governments can't
really legislate it away like a good
example is this that crime started to
take over the society but they couldn't
get any cops so they just recruited the
criminals to be the cops right yeah
and that that happens that happens in
many countries you know all you have do
is just look at the third world yeah
that's where it is and I think this I
mean the central message of the book - I
mean there's it has a lot of messages
but the central message of the book has
to do with free will in the sense and
that's why it's called a Clockwork
Orange because Alex is essentially
turned into something that looks organic
on the outside but is mechanistic on the
inside because he doesn't have any
control over his actions anymore because
he's been conditioned yes so they're
they're asking the book and the movie
are asking you to contemplate is it
better to have people doing bad things
because they choose to do bad things or
to force them to be good even though
they're not good people and they're only
doing good because doing bad is painful
for them
yeah the movies start to show that as
societies start to degenerate they start
to become more authoritarian and part of
authoritarianism is to take away
people's choice you're forcing them to
be good you're taking away their choice
of being good you when you see the movie
yes I'm talking which is essentially
what this story is about for people they
haven't seen the movie they take Alex
eventually when he's in prison and they
come up with this new program called the
Ludovico technique where they can take a
convict and force him to undergo all
this aversion therapy yes which is quite
horrible the way they did it they give
you drugs and they make you watch these
violent movies so you associate sickness
like a horrible sickness where violence
yet and from then on out you can't
commit evil and then they let you out of
prison early yeah after two weeks all
right but then the movie shows you what
happens to a person when they cannot
choose between good and evil yeah you
they can't survive and when you and
you'll see especially not in a world
that's falling apart like this dystopian
society that they put him back into yeah
yeah you can't you can't survive it so a
good person a good person can't survive
a harsh environment like that so yeah
well the interesting thing about it that
they kind of pause it and this is in the
book too and also in the movie is that
Alex is he's not sympathetic exactly um
he's like an antihero in the sense that
you sort of empathize with him even
though he's a monstrous character even
though he does monstrous things but I
think one of the reasons that you do
kind of empathize with him and relate to
him is because he is the only one who is
honest about his monstrousness yeah and
is enjoying it like everyone else and
this is kind of its this is more talking
about the movie because in the book most
a lot of the authority figures are much
more sympathetic than they are in the
movie like say the writer and
who gets beat up and everything was a
lot more sympathetic and his Alex's
guidance counselor was more sympathetic
but in the movie pretty much everyone
but alex is like a horrible screeching
caricature of a person yeah and but they
all like think they're good people and
they're trying to you know they have
good intentions I suppose but the way
that Kubrick films it it's almost like
they're trying to show that Alex is the
only normal person in this sort of
carnivalesque like world God like he
uses all these weird shots and what all
the people are really strange little
crazy hair and crazy wigs and all that
[ __ ] like things across my mind is is
this you know they're talking about this
society has room basically has removed
people's ability to choose between good
and evil especially after the Ludovico
technique it could have been implied
that maybe Alex and his drugs did not
choose to be evil that that's just that
was just a natural occurrence based on
the environment that they came up and
right so I don't think they actually
maybe they didn't actually choose to be
that way because there were other ones
like them yeah because they were the
only game what the only ones like that
so it may have been kind of like a
product of nature the nature that they
came from that's kind of a good actually
I hadn't thought of that but yeah yeah I
think that is one of the implications of
the movie right so you have to look at
both sides yeah they took away his
ability to choose evil but he didn't
choose evil so he couldn't choose good
or evil after the Ludovico technique
couldn't survive interesting all right
that is a take I don't think I've ever
heard on this movie and I've watched a
whole bunch of stuff and like I said
I've seen this movie probably bit well
he and his gang never mention what
they're doing is wrong or evil they're
having a good time they just think it's
fun
yeah they don't they don't I don't think
they have it I don't think they have a
concept of good or evil and the
interesting thing too is animalistic
yeah because Alex doesn't really in a
way Alex doesn't really have an excuse
he doesn't come from a bad home his
parents are perfectly nice you know what
I mean it's just the society around him
that's
of crumbling and everyone is kind of
going like that just listen to Beethoven
and fantasize is about people being hung
and vampires and volcanoes remember his
fantasy yeah just ultraviolence yeah
then they're taking all these weird
drugs that were offered legally in the
bars that they went to see yeah asked
and drank rum and all this weird yeah
uncle plus yeah with the milk yeah it
wasn't illegal they were just taking it
and everyone was doing everyone was
doing it and then that would they take
that and get hyped up before they go out
and do all this because the violent it
was even that one scene where they were
in the kirova milk bar and they he said
the TV people were there so even like
kind of upper-class like media people
hung out at these same places and did
all these same drugs presumably yes
because that seemed like that was all
that this place served so I think
they're just trying to say that guys
like Alex there were lots of them
because they show other ones yeah and I
think that they were just being created
by this degenerate society yeah I think
that was the implication it's kind of
like just a normal this is just the
normal outcome for what was happening
right and I think they kind of got older
generations didn't approve of it but
they see that this is the direction that
the civilization was going because yeah
I was just gonna say that that actually
was implied by particularly the the
drunken bum that they beat up at the
beginning yeah he says it pretty good
yeah you know he's talking about you
know letting the young get on to the old
yeah that's like nobody has any respect
anymore and all this other kind of stuff
and you know he didn't want to live in
this stinking world anymore and other
kind of stuff I want to talk a little
bit to you about and I mean like I said
to I think that's maybe another reason
why you empathize with Alex
not only because Malcolm McDowell is an
amazing actor and he is amazing in this
yeah would've worked without his child I
don't think it would have worked with
another actor I can't really think of
another actor who could have pulled that
off
like I said it was ad-libbed yeah
they yeah the whole singing in the rain
the rape scene yeah that that was adlib
that was that was his idea another thing
if you guys had never seen this movie
you never read the book they're not
speaking normal English yeah that's what
I was just gonna get to speak in a
language kind of like reminds me of the
language out of Blade Runner that the
where they call City speak yeah it's a
mixture of English and Russian and it's
English and Russian slang and cockney
rhyming yeah so you can understand you
can understand what they're saying just
based on the context but a lot of it is
you're like what the hell call thanks
gully wet-sand go ahead mal chicks and
stuff like that you know you figure out
that whether Tom has hands and bellies
and girls and you know yeah it's like I
I really really love I mean the book has
a lot more of it the book is very thick
the language itself I guess it's not
really a language language it's just
kind of like a dialect yeah it's a weird
words it's called nadsat yeah and
anthony burgess invented it there was a
variant about yeah there was a glossary
in the back that described but for the
movie you don't really need it yeah um
there's a couple of phrases where you
really have to like listen and be like I
wonder what that means but it's like you
know nowadays it's like somebody but
most of the time he's speaking in a very
he's almost like speaking like a very
convoluted like a Shakespearean English
there's some cockney rhyming slang
thrown in there I think he's is the word
rabbit at one point to mean I think it
means goal rabbit hole going right yeah
so I think he uses that and it's like
weird anglicized Russian so it's so it's
meant to because the older people talk
pretty normally so I'm thinking that
this is like the youth slang not
everybody talks like that just the
younger ones do yeah and what's weird is
it's con in some ways reminds me of the
Warriors remember there's no corn again
I love that I mean the Warriors might
have lifted some of its mojo off this
movie yeah the way you look at it now
they're trying to be hard you know and
tough and the Warriors you look at them
now and it just looks weak it looks
stupid but the the gangs had uniforms
yeah but it was kind of cool when you
look at it now these each gang kind of
had its own motif yeah
and that's that's really kind of what
happens nowadays in subcultures you know
you have you have Goths and have punk
rockers and you have hip-hop you know
guys that are in a hip-hop and so kind
of true-to-life and a sir
yeah way you know but it was weird you
know they got the guys from Alex's gang
just were all white with like black
derbies and top hats and athletic
protectors so yeah yeah and eyeballs
didn't head eyeballs on their cups and
weird stuff yeah Alex did I'm not sure
about the other ones it was like a
bloody eyeball like a um what do you
call that thing on your on your shirt
look uh yeah I don't know on your shirt
sleeve I'm totally having a brain fart
not mattering cuff links cuff links yeah
it's like I feel like kind of like cuff
links they were going and he has that
any has that one are they the one I like
always but I feel like a Clockwork
Orange is the only movie where the gangs
all wearing the same outfit was actually
terrifying and come in with master dick
dicks on the ends of the mass and rape
you yeah rate their what would your want
me know these weren't nice kids no they
really were I'm like I said it's almost
kind of like and the reason why this
movie was and even though the movie is
toned down substantially from the book
like I said in the book alex is like 15
years old he drugs and rapes two
ten-year-olds
which actually they turned into
consensual sex with older teenage girls
in the movies you know was fine but he's
done he does a lot more murders in the
book even the bum he beats up at the
beginning isn't like an old drunk he's
just like an old man coming out of a
library or something yeah it just kicks
his ass but um so they toned him down
but he's still a horrible horrible
monster like he still does horrible
things in the movie and yet I don't know
it's like this movie was super super
controversial when it came out in a lot
of ways
Kubrick you just withdrew it from
British because there was so much
because there were a couple of copycat
crimes do you know what they did though
now that you just reminded me of
something what that they removed the
girl gangs in the book there were girl
games yes and the girl gangs wore these
outfits and real tight outfits and one
girl game they talked about the girls
wore little pin on buttons running down
their black backs with the names of all
the guys had sex with yeah that was kind
of weird they were in a competition yeah
to see how many guys they could they
really Alicia one of the
in the movie yeah Billy boys gay man
yeah Germanic outfits with like ruffles
and yeah it's like advance yeah they
were fighting over some girl they were
gonna rape in the theatre yeah but she
got away each other don't each other in
the pianos and stuff yeah they're
playing like happy they're playing like
a happy classical music when all this is
going on the reason that I think the
reason that this movie is still was so
controversial at the time and it's still
kind of disturbing nowadays I think that
might be why is because it's so violent
but the way Kubrick films it it's almost
like makes it farcical which to me makes
it scarier there's some there's two I
think there's two pretty intense rape
scenes yeah and when I first saw him
when I was younger you know kind of
disturbing they are people scream in and
they're cutting women's clothes off and
then there's singing in the rain and
happy music going on at the same time
when the guys husbands don't you know
the girls husband's on the ground
they're beating him half to death and
you're just like you can't believe this
is happening that's you but when you
watch it today you realize that it's not
very graphics no it's not yeah it when
it fools you into thinking that you're
seeing more than you really are which
the Texas Chainsaw Massacre does that do
original kids not that not that it just
kind of infer a lot of see yeah it's
like I I feel like cuz you know Texas
Chainsaw Massacre so I came out like
back in the 70s and I feel like oh my
god you people cut up with wood
chainsaws there was not a single person
was not cut up though a chainsaw
I remember for a while they would only
show this movie after hours and certain
theaters is like a special event where
as a kid yeah this was almost an x-rated
type movie I might have gotten an X
rating I don't mouth I don't think they
were really able to show it mainstream
yeah it was real and like I said it's
even though compared to I mean you know
[ __ ] they show [ __ ] people getting
torn in half on Walking Dead on [ __ ]
TV nowadays but it's like back in those
days though they couldn't show there's
the sexual violence yeah
really like I said in some ways because
it's not as graphic and because it's
almost filmed like a ballet sort of like
because there's all of this they're all
it's all very choreographed pretty like
the fight between the droogs and Billie
boys gang you know it's not there
they're throwing each other over tables
it's all very graceful in Cirque de
Soleil and all this other kind of stuff
and then there's all this like music
going on in the background so in some
ways it's very stylized and in a way I
think it makes it more shocking I mean
either the rape scene with singing in
the rain
it's kind of like they're not taking it
seriously right but they are I mean and
when we were just right cuz like I said
I've seen this movie like a hundred
times I probably have it memorized by
it's by this point but we were we
watched it again a couple days ago you
know just to get ready for this and that
rape scene still really bothers me I'm
like I it's one of those things where
it's like I've never seen anything
simultaneously so hilarious and yet so
horrifying commented horror fun is that
you know I mean they're they're they're
raping people in darling homes without
any warning they just come in and start
raping people and they think it's a
hilarious yeah it's a movie and the
movies got background music that's like
classical music
yeah and it's just weird you know the
Justin position of yes opposites you're
going going Alex and his gang are just
mentally in a parallel universe they
don't have any empathy for these people
yeah they do not give a single no I
think is hilarious yeah and he says that
I mean in so many words they're just
driving around it's like oh well we're
gonna go and get an old ultraviolence
and that's breaking this house let's
break into this house and rape this
woman and that's just what they do
that's what they do for fun and they do
not give a single crap about anyone
steal your [ __ ] and then just you know
get rid of it yeah trash it sell it yeah
so it's in a way like I said I think
that's kind of why and the movie still
might be controversial now I don't
really know but and what's weird is this
is Stanley Kubrick yes isn't a two-bit
director you know I mean this is a well
made film it's not a flick this is a
film with a lot of implications to it
you know I mean
do you think about you go god yeah and
then Anthony Burgess is supposed to be
one of the main victims in the movie and
really he's the guy who wrote the book
yeah it kind of wrote himself into this
story and her pseudonym he's not only
the main victim he's also one of the
main perpetrators later on you'll see
yeah and like I said that's that's
another thing too about in the book like
some of the characters work close like
in the movie the writer who you know
whose wife gets rapes and dies and he
gets his ass kicked and he's crippled
for life become a revolutionary yeah
he's um he's much older in the movie
than in the book in the book he was
about the same age as the woman was in
the movie so it's it's almost kind of
like Kubrick like I said he almost made
all the other characters like all the
other authority figures grotesque yeah
and what's weird is like they're kind of
normal all the authority figures are
also kind of perverse yeah not really in
the book yeah yeah was it I don't like
truancy officer yeah is definitely
concerned about him but he's also
definitely into him yeah that is a
record yeah Dean he then he sits on his
bed he's like patting the bed like to
sit next yes yeah my boy just it's weird
it's it's kind of like they're just
trying to show you that I guess you
could say the Overton Window of this
society has just expanded way out where
basically anything goes so the youth
that just run around raping people yeah
I guess everybody in this movie is
terrible
I think the only sympathetic character
is the prison chaplain I don't know then
him maybe not I think the prison
chaplain thought he was gonna get a
piece maybe
can I speak to you alone over there
brother and he's like it could be read
sure yeah it could be read like that
sure I think that that was and probably
yeah I'm kind of think so okay and then
the prison warden one of the main not
the warden but the main prison officer
the crazy guy doing all the
goose-stepping and everything in jail
and screaming yeah I mean
problem is just taking everything way
too seriously you know that Stephen King
and common officious prick but yeah like
guys so I don't there was something
wrong with everybody in the movie yeah
everyone sucked everyone think there's I
think I think they're just trying to
show a civilization on the edge yeah the
word nobody's really functional I mean I
his parents were fairly cinematic no
they weren't I mean sort of know the dad
was basically a UH
kind of useless he wasn't doing it yeah
but they weren't Lisa letting all this
happen they weren't like aggressively
mean or anything I meant no no they were
and they were kind of like passive yes
so passive they were just letting him
run wild and commit crimes yes oh no it
wasn't good yeah you know he wasn't a
good example of a father he was totally
he was you know cooked out you know what
he was remember he was just yeah well
okay whatever you say I don't know what
he's up to at night you know it's like
that yeah yes so that's not been that's
not being they didn't even know what he
was doing no link now that we don't know
yeah and that's and this is allowing a
disaster to happen so I'm gonna call
[ __ ] on that no that was bad
well actually although one of the better
things they did was that what is when
Alex got let out of prison after the
Ludovico technique and he went back to
the house they actually did put their
foot down and not let him move back in
uh no that was the border well yeah he
merely he's like you know I know about
you what you did to these wonderful
people here yeah I guess we can't just
ask him to leave and just know so we
don't yet everybody was [ __ ] up yeah
yeah then the new border really was just
in on it because he had a place to live
yeah ya know everyone was out for
themselves yeah yeah you're right yeah
they were all out themselves but yeah so
like I laid into it for a negative point
of view and I'm looking at it from a
Sunnah from a society falling apart no
they're all selfish yeah they're all
selfish or they're blind or they're weak
you know stuff like that and like I said
I think that's probably why I mean to
the extent that you empathize with with
Alex
which you kind of do particularly at the
end when he's cured um you know and
everybody's like yeah he's back to being
he's back to being a psycho bet well it
I don't know like cuz I kind of feel
like that might be I think that the
final scene uh where he before he says I
was cured all right when he's has that
fantasy yeah do you did you notice
something interesting about that fantasy
that he was having that was different
from his other ones what was that it
appeared that the sex was consensual it
also appeared the woman was on top in a
dominant position there was also no
violence
so republic in public was kind of weird
though that's not inherently cured all
right but I think the main win was is
that he got that settlement yeah he may
he made up they gave him a whole bunch
of money to hush money to keep him with
keep him yeah well they gave him a job
with a lot of women with a high sound
when I remember the book they gave him a
bunch of money to the image ah yeah but
they also gave him yes I didn't want him
to like she wanted me whether they did
there was a big election happen and it
involved a bunch of political parties in
the book and they didn't want him going
to the news yeah and and and talking
about this because it would affect some
up-and-coming politician yeah you know
the whole society was corrupt but like I
said the that final scene his final
fantasy like after he says that he's
cured work where the implication could
be either he's returned to his
psychopathic ways or he kind of has like
he got his freewill back but he wasn't
it's evolving it wasn't as bad as it was
maybe because like I was older he had
been in prison for a few years yeah he
was in prison for two yes yeah two years
and then that would have made him
probably about in the book 18 maybe yeah
he was 18 in last chapter when he
decided that he was just saying he kind
of naturally matured maybe a little bit
yeah Kubrick does all kinds of stuff in
the blood I mean in the book it didn't
it didn't make any implications did they
just said that they had reversed to the
condition
that was basically yeah from what I
remember yeah which meant that if he was
a nut before he would continue being a
nut now there's a sequel to it to the to
that book and evidently in the sequel
he's he's a normal guy he grew out of it
yeah well that was like I said that was
the implication of the the chapter 21
which was in the British book but not in
the American book okay
he's basically so maybe that's the see
when he's 18 he's just like I said I
think he sees one of his droogs
out like talking to a girl you know in
acting normal and stuff and talking like
a grown-up instead of in their room
that's that language and he starts
contemplating oh you know maybe I'll get
married and maybe all of a sudden and I
don't want him to end up like me and
stuff like that which like I said I
could buy that more if it had happened
later on like I feel like an 18 year old
dude doesn't have that level of insight
no um you know particularly one that
it's six G's maybe back in the Signet
has been his entire youth being a terror
yeah I just I don't think that there is
that quicker reversal is there anything
else you want to say about this movie
this is a must see yeah like I said it's
like the I could I could get one of our
fans from Mexico said he'd never seen
this no he'd never seen he'd never see
the shining oh yeah I'm almost kind of
jealous because it's like I wish I had
never but you know what I mean it's
these two movies the well the shining
and a Clockwork Orange are probably two
my favorite movies of all time bus and
all of Kubrick's movies yeah there's a
blu-ray for sale on eBay that has 2001
Clockwork horns and the shining on it
you can get all three movies for about
15 bucks on blu-ray men and they look at
them there's a lot of extras it's a
great it's a great yeah each disc has a
[ __ ] ton of Acts yeah and it's not one
disc gets three discs yeah same package
yeah 15 bucks it was such a good deal we
got a target like I said but yeah all
those movies are eminently rewatchable
yeah we've watched shining we can watch
shining once a week I could watch that
every goddamn day and ever
same with clockwork orange' yeah like
I've watched it so many times that I
haven't memorized thousand ones a bit
long but you can always run that in the
back yeah I could map that on the
background but actually cliff whenever
clockwork orange' or The Shining would
come on TV I would always sit down and
watch it over and over again it's like a
fantastic fantastic movie very
disturbing to watch even nowadays I
think it's still kind of disturbing just
the way it is because it's so grotesque
it's got a lot of Kubrick stuff in it
you'll see little messages and yeah in
the background and it's probably the
most Kubrick Ian movie there there is
but yeah so I definitely recommend it if
you haven't seen it like I said I'm kind
of jealous of you because I wish I could
go back in and see it for the first time
yet for the first time yeah especially
if I could see it on the big screen that
would be rad yeah cuz I never got to but
anyway I hope you enjoyed our little
rambling analysis of a Clockwork Orange
go see it if you haven't also remember
if you like the show to like share
subscribe on all your social media check
out all our other channels what do we
have vo [ __ ] you yeah
dailymotion kinda even though slowly
slowly getting upon taking forever also
if you'd like to financially support the
show you can go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
podcast wordpress.com and there's a link
in the sidebar to a PayPal account where
you can give a one-time donation and be
sure to check out our regular episodes
which come out every Tuesday and our
movie reviews which come out every
Friday and that will do it for this
installment see you later